hey everyone Welcome to our devops
interview questions video
whether you're a seasoned professional
or just starting to explore the world of
devops this video will provide you with
the valuable insights into devops common
interview questions and answers we will
cover a range of topics which will help
you feel confident and prepared for your
next devops interview
so let's dive in and enhance your
understanding of this Dynamic and
essential field but before we begin let
me ask you a quick question so what does
devops aim to achieve in software
development making programs lower and
more complex an option b is isolating
development and operation teams
completely options is enhancing
collaboration between development and
operation teams an option D is ignoring
Automation and continuous indication so
these are the four options now you can
pause this video and answer in the
comment section below alright now let's
understand what is devops devops is like
a teamwork approach for making computer
programs better and faster it combines
the work of software developers and
operation teams the goal is to help them
work together and use tools that speed
up the process and make fewer mistakes
they also keep an eye on the programs
and fix problems early This Way
businesses can release programs faster
with few errors and everyone works
better together if you want to learn
more about this then check post graduate
program in devops to understand from the
basics to advanced concepts this
postgraduate program in devops is
crafted in partnership with Caltech ctme
this comprehensive course aligns your
expertise with industry benchmarks
experience or Innovative Blended
learning merging live online devops
certification sessions with immersive
labs for practical Mastery Advanced your
career with Hands-On training that meets
industry demands alright now let's move
on to the first question of devops
interview question which is what do you
know about devops so think of a devops
like teamwork in the IT world it's
become really important because it helps
teams work together smoothly to make
computer programs faster and with fewer
mistakes imagine a soccer team everyone
works together to win the game devops is
similar it's when computer developers
and operations people team up to make
software better they start working
together from the beginning when they
plan what the software will be like
until they finish and put it out for
people use this Teamwork Makes sure
things go well and the software works
great so this was about devops now
moving on to the second question which
is how is devops different from agile
methodology devops is like a teamwork
culture where the people who create the
software and the people who make it work
smoothly join forces this helps in
always improving and updating the
software without any big bricks agile is
a way of making softwares that's like
taking small steps towards instead of
big jumps it's about releasing small
parts of the software quickly and
getting feedback from the users this
helps in solving any issues or
differences between what users want and
what developers are making so you can
answer this question in this way all
right moving on to the third question
which is what are the ways in which a
build can be scheduled slash run in
Jenkins
so as you can see there are four ways by
source code management commits second is
after the completion of other builds
third is scheduled to run at a specified
time and fourth one is manual build
requests so if the interviewer asks then
you can answer these four ways in which
a build can be scheduled in Jenkins all
right now the fourth question is what
are the different phases in devops so
the various phases of devops lifecycle
are as follows so as you can see first
is plan so initially there should be a
plan for the type of application that
needs to be developed getting a rough
feature of the development process is
always a good idea then code the
application is coded as per the end user
requirements then there is build build
application by integrating various codes
formed in previous steps after that
there is test this is the most crucial
step of the application development test
the application and rebuild if necessary
then there is integrate so multiple
codes from different programmers are
integrated into one after integrate
there is deploy so code is deployed into
a cloud environment for further usage it
is ensured that any new changes do not
affect the functioning of a high traffic
website after that there is operate so
operations are performed on the code if
required then there is Monitor
applications performance is monitored
changes are made to meet the end user
requirements so these all were the
different phases of devops and here we
have explained each one of these you can
go through it and if the interviewer
have asked you this question you can
answer it in a similar way alright now
moving on to the next question which is
mention some of the core benefits of
devops so the core benefits of devops
are as follows first of all we'll say
technical benefits first technical
benefit of devops's continuous software
delivery then second is less complex
problems to manage third is early
detection and faster correction of
defects then here comes the business
benefits the first benefit of devops
that is business benefit of devops is
faster delivery of features so it allows
faster delivery of features then there
is stable operation environment
then third one is improve communication
and collaboration between the teams so
these were the business benefits so here
we have discussed both technical
benefits and business benefits all right
now the next question is how will you
approach a project that needs to
implement devops so here are the simpler
terms here's how we can bring devops
into a specific project using these
Steps step one would be first we look at
how things are currently done and figure
out where we can make them better this
makes about two to three weeks then we
can plan for what changes to make then
step two would be we create a small test
to show that our plan works when
everyone agrees with it we can start
making the real changes and put the plan
into action then third step would be we
are all set to actually use devops we do
things like keeping track of different
versions of our work putting everything
together testing it and making it
available to the users we also watch how
it's working to make sure everything
goes smoothly by doing these steps right
the keeping track of changes putting
everything together testing and watching
how it's going we are all set to use
devops in our project
so this is how you can approach a
project that needs to implement in
devops and this is how you can answer
this question all right moving on to the
question number seven which is what is
the difference between continuous
delivery and continuous deployment all
right so first would be continuous
delivery so it ensures code can be
safely deployed on production whereas
continuous deployment here every change
that passes the automated test is
deployed to production automatically
then in continuous delivery it ensures
business applications and services
functions as expected whereas in
continuous deployment it makes software
development and the release process
faster and more robust in continuous
delivery delivers every change to a
production like environment through
rigorous and automatic testing whereas
in continuous deployment there is no
explicit approval from a developer and
requires a developed culture of
monitoring so these were the three
points that you you can highlight while
differentiating between continuous
delivery and continuous deployment all
right so this was the question number
seven now moving on to the question
number eight which is name three
security mechanisms of Jenkins uses to
authenticate users so here we have to
name three security mechanisms so first
one would be Jenkins uses an internal
database to store user data and
credentials second is Jenkins can use
the lightweight directory access
protocol that is ldap server to
authenticate users third one is Jenkins
can be configured to employ the
authentication mechanism that the
deployed application server uses so
these were the three mechanisms that
Jenkins uses to authenticate users all
right now moving on to the question
number nine which is how does continuous
monitoring help you maintain the entire
architecture of the system so continuous
monitoring within devops involves the
ongoing identification detection and
reporting of any anomalies or security
risk across the entire system
infrastructure it guarantees the proper
functioning of services applications and
resources on servers by overseeing
server statuses it accesses the accuracy
of application operations this practice
also facilitates uninterpreted audits
transaction scrutinity and regulated
surveillance
so this was about the question number
nine that was how does continuous
monitoring help you maintain the entire
architecture of the system now moving on
to the question number 10 which is what
is the role of AWS in devops so in the
realm of devops AWS assumes several
rules first one would be adaptable
services so it offers adaptable
pre-configured Services eliminating the
necessity for software installation or
configuration second one is design for
expansion whether managing one instance
or expanding two thousand AWS Services
accommodate seamless scalability then
there is automated operations AWS
empowers task and process automation
freeing up valuable time for inventing
Pursuits the next one is enhanced
security
AWS and entity and accesses management
that is IAM allows precise user
permissions and policy establishment
then the last one is extensive partner
Network so AWS Fosters a vast partner
Network that integrates with and
enhances its service offerings so these
were the role of awfs in the realm of
devops all right now moving on to the
question number 11 name three important
devops kpis the three important kpis are
as follows first one is mean time to
failure recovery this is the average
time taken to recover from a failure
second kPa is deployment frequency the
frequency in which the deployment occurs
is called deployment frequency third one
is percentage of field deployments the
number of times the deployment fails is
called percentage of field deployments
so these were the three important devops
kpis this question can also be asked all
right moving on to question number 12
which is how is IAC implemented using
AWS
so comments by discussing traditional
methods involving scripting commands
into files followed by testing in
isolated environments prior to
deployment notice how this practice is
giving way to infrastructure as code IAC
comparable to code for various Services
IAC aided by AWS empowers developers to
craft accesses and manage infrastructure
components descriptively utilizing
formats like Json or yaml this Fosters
streamline development and expeditious
implementation of alterations in
infrastructure all right now moving on
to question number 13 which is describe
the branching strategies you have used
they'll ask you this question so to test
our knowledge the purpose of branching
and our experience of branching at a
past job this question is usually asked
so here we will discuss topics that can
help considering this devops interview
question so release branching we can
clone the develop Branch to create a
release branch once it has enough
functionality for a release this Branch
kicks off the next release cycle thus no
new features can be contributed Beyond
this point the things that can be
contributed are documentation generation
bug fixing and other release related
tasks the release is merged into master
and given a version number once it is
ready to ship it should also be merged
back into the development branch which
may have evolved since the initial
release so this was the first one then
there is future branching this branching
model maintains all modifications for a
specific feature contained within a
branch the branch gets merged into
Master once the feature has been
completely tested and approved by using
tests that are automated then the third
branching is Task branching in this
branching model every task is
implemented in its respective Branch the
task key is mentioned in the branch name
we need to Simply look at the task key
in the branch name to discover which
code which tasks so these were the
branching strategies that you can say
that you have used or if you have really
used it otherwise you can say something
else
all right moving on to question number
14 which is can you explain the shift
left to reduce failure Concept in devops
so shifting left within the devops
framework is a concept aimed to enhance
security for performance and related
aspects to illustrate consider the
entity of Davos processes currently
security evaluations occur before the
deployment stage by employing the left
ship approach we can introduce security
measures during the earlier development
phase denoted as the left
this integration spans on multiple
phases encompassing pre-development and
testing not confined to development
alone this holistic integration is
likely to elevate security measures by
identifying vulnerabilities at initial
stage leading to a more fortified
overall process now moving on to the
question number 15 which is what is blue
teen deployment pattern so this approach
involves seamless deployment aimed at
minimizing downtime it entails shifting
traffic from one instance to another
requiring their placement of outdating
code and a new version to integrate
fresh code
the updated version resides in a green
environment while the older one remains
in a blue environment after modifying
the existing version a new instance is
generated from the old one to execute
the updating instance ensuring a
smoother transition so the main focus of
this approach is smooth deployment
all right so this was question number
15. now moving on to the question number
16 which is what is continuous testing
so continuous testing involves the
automated execution of tests within the
software delivery pipeline
offerings immediate insights into
potential business rates within the
latest release
by seamlessly integrating testing into
every stage of the software developer
icipit I repeat by seamlessly
integrating testing into the every stage
of software delivery life cycle
continuous testing minimizes issues
during transition phases and empowers
development teams and instant feedback
this approach accelerates developer
efficiency by obtaining the need to
re-run all tests after each update and
project rebuild culminating in notable
gains in speed and productivity so this
was about continuous testing
now moving on to question number 17 what
are the benefits of automation testing
so some of the benefits of automation
testing includes
first it helps to save money and time
second is unattended execution can be
easily done third one is huge test
matrices can be easily tested the next
one is parallel execution is enabled
then there is reduced human generated
errors which results in improved
accuracy last one is repeated test task
execution is supported
so these are the benefits of automation
testing
coming to question number 18 which is
what is a Docker file used for
so a Docker file is used for creating
Docker images using the build command
with a Docker image any user can run the
code to create Docker containers once
Docker image is built it's uploaded in
Docker registry
from the docker registry users can get
the docker image and build new
containers whenever they want so this is
what Docker file is used for
coming to question number 19 which is
what is the process for reverting a
commit that has already been pushed and
made public so there are two ways to do
that to revert a comment so first would
be remove or fix the bad file in a new
commit and push it to the remote
Repository
then commit it to the remote repository
using get commit minus M commit message
again git commit minus M commit message
so this is the first way then second is
create a new commit that undoes all the
changes that were made in the bad
comment
and use the command get reward
commit ID as you can see in the screen
First Command also on the second command
also the second command says get revert
commit ID commit ID will have to put the
commit ID all right so question number
19 this was now moving on to the last
question which is question number 20 how
do you find a list of files that have
been changed in a particular command so
the answer would be the command to get a
list of files that have been changed in
a particular comment is
git diff 3 minus r then there is commit
hash so this command as you can see on
the screen get div free minus r commit
hash you can put it then example is also
there like
commit hash
87e6735
f21b so this example as you can see on
the screen then there is minus r flag
instruct so the command to list
individual files and commit hash will
list all the files that were changed or
added in that command so there's telling
about the as you can see minus our
functionality minus r is a flag that
instructs the command to list individual
files and commit hash will list all the
files that were changed or added in that
comment
so these were the top 20 devops
interview questions that you must
understand if you are planning to give a
devops interview
so in this video we have explored key
Concepts methodologies and best
practices that are crucial in fostering
collaboration between development and
operation streams by understanding the
principles discussed here you are well
equipped to navigate the dynamic
landscape of devops and drive successful
software delivery
foreign
[Music]
we're actually brothers and we live here
in Alberta Canada we do a lot of things
together
and this time we decided to take a
course in devops from Simply learn the
course proved to be very beneficial for
both our careers yeah I got a promotion
after the course and I got a hired with
a new company
I'm actually a mechanical engineering
graduate and I've been working at my
company for the last four years in 2020
I came to know that my company was
starting the hiring process for a devops
infrastructure team at the time I was
working as an implementation specialist
and my colleagues recommend that I take
a course in devops if I wanted to be
part of a team so I started doing my
research and then he came to me saying
that he was also looking for a devops
course yeah I'm full enough I actually
found the course through Instagram but
you know my situation was slightly
different I had been working as a
geomatic field technician for about four
years but I wanted to change my career
into something that involved more
programming and automation so when I
came across with this course I said you
know what let's take it
and caltex name was definitely a
deciding factor in July 2021 we got our
certifications and I immediately posted
that on my LinkedIn profile you know
coincidentally in November of that same
year we got the good news
and I got hired as a dis developer
which has allowed me to do way more
programming which is what I wanted to do
around that time I got promoted to the
devops infrastructure team and saw a 21
salary hike the overall course was
awesome but the part that I enjoyed the
most was a Docker certification training
you know what I also really enjoyed the
docker certification training I think
there were brothers after all
yeah the experience was amazing and
being able to study together was
definitely very nice yeah it brought us
back to those good old days when we were
going to school together thank you for
watching and remember that embracing
devops can lead to streamline workflows
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign